hey baby
stop selling wheat all right you got
your whole life ahead of you
he said [ __ ] you [ __ ] i got kids to
feed that's a god
i told chris rock i was going to the
comedy cellar here in new york he said i
am going to come down i said chris you
i'm working on some stuff come down
i want to know what you think we're
close and we always give each other
opinions on what we're doing and
where we feel this can go or that can go
just punch up so he comes down
he's like oh my god cat funny i said you
going up he said yeah i'm gonna try some
stuff out too chris goes up
dave pops in later that night me and
chris were there talking chappelle comes
in
we say you going up he said yeah me and
chris go downstairs
so we can watch dave keep in mind me and
chris are excited we just worked on new
material
right chris gave me some good beats he
went on i gave him some good beats
dave went on stage and was so good
right and me and chris just took what we
had we balled it up we threw it away
we threw it in the trash we threw it i
said i said
i'm so disgusted with where my level of
thinking was after seeing where dave was
i gotta go back in the gym this man is
unbelievable i'm not talking about just
his stand up how he interacts with
people random people random fans
who are in minneapolis minnesota white
kid just freaks out
oh my god dave chavel
he just loses his [ __ ] and i'm like hey
man relax relax
you know cause people think cuz i'm so
big i'm in security and [ __ ]
i'm like like he's like come on man oh
my god
dave chabelle please come up to my
apartment i have some weed
and dave looked at me and i looked back
at him i was like i am out of weed bros
let's check out what this situation is
let's see where it takes us so we go up
to his apartment i go in i see this
giant
jar full of weed just like white people
have and i take my nugget
i was like thank you so much and we're
about to walk out
and the entire time he starts pounding
on his roommate's door
wake up bro wake up we got
[ __ ] dave shipped out into an
apartment
but he won't wake up to save his life
and we're leaving he's like please take
a picture
please take and dave was like hey man
we're moving in the night right now
he started walking down his stairs and
he's
up on the top of the stairs he's like no
one
is gonna move
what happened was uh we were out here we
had a tv deal blah blah blah
they gave his car you know what kind of
car you want yeah
ford mustang um dave never drove before
so
first thing at first they gave him a
town car
and he was like man give a black man a
town car
ain't trying to say i'm a pimp they gave
him another car he wrecked that car
anyway
he finally gets the car he wants he
comes to my door he's like
man let's go let's go let's go cruising
it's all right let's go cruising
back then was the smoking period so we
find a coffee shop
right i park my car he parks his right i
got my top down
cds in there we go on the uh now we're
solving all the world's problems of
course
right and um in the middle of it there
goes man i think i just seen my car go
by i said dave
you're paranoid he's you're high now man
it's the same
color it's a lot of toyota celicas is
silver that's not it well long story
short we walked out about an hour later
someone stole his car man the police
took it
police did not dig it the funniest part
was he's standing in the space
but man he's i'm thugging
wearing my leather jacket playing my
marriage a blast
and then he goes i just put gas in it
he can make anything funny and you're
baked just laughing your ass off
i just wrecked in the middle of the
street laughing so hard
dave you know i call him the honorable
dave chappelle all praises do
uh has owns a bunch of land
in ohio that's what you do when you go
to ohio right you just buy a bunch of
land
and on his land he's got a corn field
and he chopped down some corn and built
the stage
and you know then at some point in
dave's got like a weed
mushroom chef that prepares amazing
meals
with weed and mushrooms right so uh
tiffany haddish drank the mushroom tea
and cut our hair the next day
[Music]
what else i did on my wonderful over my
wonderful holiday break
i went down to the comedy store
did a set had a great time and i was
driving home
you know and i'm driving along sunset
i'm just starting to [ __ ] listen to
my tunes and all of a sudden i go by
this venue
and i look and what do i see i see dave
chappelle
and john mayer are doing a show i'm like
get the [ __ ] out of here
right so i call up a buddy of mine that
books all the shows
and i said hey what's what's the story
with this does john mayer
you know come out with his band you know
does dave go on first does john go on
first blah blah he's like no what
happens is
john comes out plays like four songs he
brings dave out
dave does stand up for an hour an hour
and a half and then he brings john back
out
and then they just sort of riff
as dave talks about [ __ ] john will play
the music underneath and i was like i
gotta [ __ ] see that
so uh me and my me and the lovely nia we
went down there uh because i never take
a route on new year's eve
because that is the original st
patrick's day
um plus i go to the rose bowl the next
day so i need to get my sleep before i
get absolutely hammered and passed out
in a [ __ ] chair
for a couple hours missing my meatball
sub
um so we went down there and um
just had such a great [ __ ] night
and um i don't think i've ever seen that
i don't think i've ever seen two people
that [ __ ] talented
like there's usually one genius and then
surrounded by a bunch of people who are
just sitting there isn't he amazing
i'm so happy to be playing bass with
this genius or i'm so happy to be
[ __ ] i don't know
whatever the [ __ ] else i'm so happy to
be in the ice capades with this twirling
genius right
it was two of them and what i kind of
noticed about both of them is that they
just so
like most genius minds they they kind of
they get rid of all the [ __ ] white
noise everything about every
bit that chappelle did was just like
there was no fat on it and he got right
to the [ __ ] point
another thing that i loved was um
i can't believe that i've been in this
business long enough
that we're like the older guys now
it always blows my mind that i'm like
five years older than dave chappelle
because he was already a made guy when i
came in
so i always look at him like he's got 10
years on me
you know or 15 and you know just when i
watch his act i'm like this guy's
clearly been doing this
a good couple of decades longer than me
and the reality is i think he's only
been doing it like six years longer than
i have or something like that
he's [ __ ] amazing and
what i love too is
just he's that same
um with all that's changed everybody
getting offended all of this [ __ ]
crap by you get in trouble
he hasn't changed at all
he's just like that same guy that i saw
way
back in the day when i used to go to the
boston comedy club
and watch him go on at like two in the
morning
and just start murdering at two in the
[ __ ] morning and i remember he's
always sit there going how
how do you do that how are you that
funny at two in the morning
in front of a crowd that gave up on the
show like an hour ago
and they're tired and they just want to
go home that second he steps on stage
boom he just like
he just starts [ __ ] killing so um
you know dave's up there murdering me
and nia are like just [ __ ] laughing
dying having a great time and um
and then he brings john mayer back and i
don't want to ruin the show for any
because i don't know how many they're
going to do
but uh basically if dave was up there
and he was just saying like you know
i was watching [ __ ] hawaii 5-0 like
john whatever she [ __ ] rips it's
clearly that dave is just ripping
like mayor can play whatever the [ __ ] he
said and dave said that at one point he
goes i don't know if you guys realize
this [ __ ]
but john mayer can play whatever he
hears
and then he just started doing all this
crazy [ __ ] like
making his guitar sound like a cat or a
car
beeping like it went beyond i could play
songs like he could just do noises
around the house
but it was [ __ ]
it was [ __ ] incredible um so if you
get a chance i don't know
you know if you get a chance to go see
the show definitely uh
definitely go do it um all right and
with that let me uh
speaking of which let me promote this
um uh the patrice o'neill comedy benefit
i forgot to [ __ ] ask dave chappelle
if he ever wanted to come in and do it
god damn it
um anyways